on Palm Sunday South Bend mayor Pete
Budaj edge threw himself into the
presidential unveiling party and that's
why I'm here today to tell a different
story
than make America great again because
there's a myth being sold to industrial
and rural communities the myth that we
can stop the clock and turn it back now
it never mind that Trump has sparked a
manufacturing job Renaissance that's
been unseen in decades now since he took
office more than 450,000 manufacturing
jobs have been added to this economy but
when you got fancy magazine cover
spreads and media acolytes who needs
these facts and all the right media
types have you notice they're still
dejected after the Russian collusion
flop they found themselves a brand new
political Messiah a really special day
yes yesterday everybody stopped they
were watching Tiger and they watched me
repeat and I don't know 10 years from
now 20 years from now just maybe a day
that a lot of people look back on and
and and see see history being made it
was a remarkable day and two remarkable
events you're right to call them both
remarkable no scintillating analysis as
always they're comparing Tiger Woods one
of the greatest athletes of all time who
wins the Masters after an 11-year
drought that included huge personal and
physical struggles to mayor Pete mayor
of a mid-sized City who announces he's
running for president
what and by the way Tiger is an original
Buddha judge sounds an awfully like he's
channeling the last Democrat president I
recognize the audacity
of doing this as a Midwestern millennial
mayor I recognize that there is a
certain presumptuousness in this a
certain audacity to this announcement we
live in a moment that compels us each to
act change is coming ready or not
we are choosing hope over fear we're
choosing unity over division and sending
a powerful message that change is coming
to America well beneath the Obama
cadence that was pretty good by the way
and the boy scout demeanor mayor Pete's
rap doesn't quite add up at least not
yet now here's the first principle of
his campaign first comes freedom
something our conservative friends have
come to think of as their own but let me
tell you freedom does not belong to just
one political party well that's just
silly and patently false who said it did
but when you have little to run on in a
race with 17 other Democrat primary
challengers if it sounds good
just say it our conservative friends
care about freedom but they they only
make it part of the way they only see
freedom from as though government were
the only thing that can make somebody
unfree but it's not true your neighbor
can make you unfree okay well he didn't
quite explain what that meant he just
went on to the next thing but could your
neighbor take away your freedom a
neighbor can disagree with you wouldn't
be annoying and even commit a crime or a
civil infraction against you but how can
a neighbor make you on free will find
out maybe well mayor Pete seems to see
the federal government as a crusading
force for good that should be used to
protect us from our neighbors now
understand this that view itself is
pretty radical in Federalist 45 James
Madison explained that the powers
delegated by the proposed constitution
of the federal government are few and
defined those which are to remain and
the state governments are numerous and
indefinite now the sentiment of what the
federal government the federal
government should do
our should be was repeated by numerous
state delegations during the
constitutional ratification process
including by New York now they
understood that freedom contracts with
an ever-expanding federal government
president presents because it moves into
every area of your life but again for a
supposedly trailblazing candidate Budaj
it's just another conventional liberal
women's equality is freedom
because you're not free if your
reproductive health choices are dictated
by male politicians with us okay well
we've heard that before but abortion is
freedom Oh certainly not for the unborn
child in the womb or for that matter the
child born after born after a botched
abortion in this new Democrat Party I
don't see the freedom there
well again push past the carefully
studied meticulously measured rhetoric
and what Mayor Pete really has is a beef
with our Constitution and we can't say
it's much of a democracy when twice in
my lifetime the Electoral College has
overruled the American people why should
our vote in Indiana only count once or
twice in a century or your vote in
Wyoming or New York okay well we live in
a representative democracy not a pure
democracy maybe they left out that
entire discussion from the Harvard
government lectures but the Electoral
College protects the votes of people in
states like Indiana otherwise back to
the framers this is government of by and
for the people of California and New
York oh and by the way this
revolutionary candidate is basically a
carbon copy of the most radical house
freshmen on the issue of climate change
asking all the sceptics are you saying
for instance that some of the talk about
retrofitting every building in America
or trying to make the country carbon
free by 2030 that's just unrealistic
we're gonna have to do it look at 2030
if we can't do carbon free then we'll do
net carbon free which means that we're
taking out as much as we're putting in
now translation a massive wealth
confiscations needed forced and overseen
by the federal government to fulfill
this green New Deal and by the way a
government whose elites under President
Pete would decide which cars need to be
sent to the trash heap and which
buildings are up to code mayor Pete is
academically very accomplished and he
deserves real respect for serving in the
Naval Reserves seven months in
Afghanistan
but he's a run-of-the-mill liberal on
most issues and he's running against an
economy that is on fire because of the
policies of President Trump who has
largely kept us out of more foreign
entanglements that most liberals are
against so if this were maybe george w
bush presiding over a cratering economy
with an unpopular war abroad maybe a guy
like Buddha judge would stand a strong
chance but given the prosperity at home
at America's current place in the world
the Left had better find a new Messiah
there's going to be no resurrection for
this one and that's the angle